-Pelotaunt has all
the upgraded features
that keep you moving
out of spite,
features like gaslighting
you about how far you've gone...
-Hey, it says I did four rides,
but I did five.
-No, I think you did four.
It's a computer.
♪♪
-Okay, Peloton, let's go!
-Only Peloton delivers 24/7
nonstop motivation
from world-class instructors
right in your home.
-You smashed it.
-But what if you're
the kind of person
who doesn't respond to
encouragement?
-You did this.
-If I hear the phrase, "You can
do it," I literally won't,
just to prove a point.
-If anyone yells
that I can do one more,
I will immediately get off this
thing, unplug it, and go smoke.
-I cannot be cheerleaded.
I know myself.
-For those people,
we introduce Pelotaunt,
the only exercise bike that
provides you with personalized,
at-home negative reinforcement
and relentless criticism.
-Ready to do this?
-No.
-I don't give a [bleep]
I get paid either way.
-Hey, I-I guess I could do
a little bit.
Look.
Come back.
-Using patented passive
aggression,
each Pelotaunt instructor
will pull from a toolkit
of emotional manipulation styles
guaranteed to get
even the laziest cyclist moving,
techniques such
as snotty disdain...
-Really nice big T-shirt.
Do you wear that to swim?
-No.
-Well, thanks for wearing it
here.
-[ Exhales sharply ]
-...insincere praise...
-Okay, Susan, I know
you just had a baby,
so go at your own pace.
-What? I-I didn't have a baby.
-Oh. Are you sure you didn't?
-Yeah.
-Oh, okay.
Well, maybe one day.
-...and avoidant attachment
style that will put you
in a state of
complete codependence.
-Well, I know that,
but I was trying to figure out
what to do with that.
-Uh, should I go up a level?
-I think she's just
a lost cause.
-If you want to talk to me,
I'm right here.
Look, look at me, guys.
I'm doing it.
-No corny inspirational speeches
here.
Just withering judgment sure
to get your heart pumping
and your brain thinking,
"Am I bad?"
-Let's give it up for Mike,
who's working out in his garage.
-Oh, uh, no, uh, this is
my living room.
-What?
-I feel mentally broken down,
but, hey, I can see my abs.
-I hate exercise,
but I hate Sarah more.
-This is you.
You're like, "Whoa, whoa, whoa."
-Pelotaunt has all the upgraded
features that keep you
moving out of spite, features
like gaslighting you
about how far you've gone...
-Hey, it says I did four rides,
but I did five.
-No, I think you did four.
It's a computer.
-...live video of your own ass
from behind with
an exaggerated fisheye lens...
-Oh, God, is that mine?
-A constant picture-in-picture
of an elderly woman
who's like 1,000 times
better than you...
-Is there a way
to turn her off?
She's kicking my ass.
-...a humiliating soundtrack
that will make you feel stupid.
[ "Curb Your Enthusiasm" theme
plays ]
-And stop.
-[ Exhales sharply ]
-That was good.
-It was?
[ Crying ]
-Pelotaunt.
Also available in "Mom."
-Well, this was a dumb
thing to buy.
Great job, Mike.
-Welcome, welcome.
My name is Phoenix,
as in the University of.
Soulcycle's closed right now,
so we put together this
livestream with the trainer fam.
We may not have bikes,
but that won't stop us
from charging you
to watch us work out.
Let's go!
-What up, what up,
Soulcycle computer?
They call me Lee,
short for Harvey Oswald.
It's crazy to think that people
could be watching this
anywhere from Los Angeles
to California.
I've been hearing a lot
about squatters -- right? --
so let's get 'em!
I always try to keep
a positive attitude.
I moved to New York two days
before quarantine.
Shout-out to my roommate,
who catfished me.
He ain't no leggy blonde,
but it's his personality
I fell in love with.
Let's go!
-My name is Korona with a "K."
I'm always overcoming adversity.
When I was little, they told me
I was pretty enough to act
but not model!
So I joined TikTok,
where I do neither.
Let's go!
-I am Toyota,
and I hear a lot of people
talking about antibodies.
I am pro-body!
Quarantine, day two, let's go!
Whoo!
-I am Robert,
like Julia Robert.
And I'm good vibes only.
Who do I stay home for?
Me, because I'm quarantined
and on house arrest.
Two birds. Let's go.
-What's up? I'm Molly.
Sorry, I'm on Molly.
I'm not gonna get COVID-19,
'cause I'm 22.
Liberate Michigan!
Let's go!
Ooh, it's burning now.
-This pandemic has affected
everyone.
Coachella -- canceled.
South by Southwest -- canceled.
Bill Cosby -- canceled.
How dare?!
We need doctors right now.
Let's push!
-Commit to what you start!
I'm finishing "Ozark." Let's go!
-I'm on a juice cleanse
right now -- Clorox juice.
Eat clean!
-This one's called
the bow and arrow.
It's gonna go way back.
Oh!
Ow!
-My mantra?
"Eat, pray, pray."
That's right.
I'm hot and religious.
It's a trap.
Let's go!
-Just because we're in
quarantine doesn't mean
we can't connect, meet up,
go to the beach, hug, touch,
kiss an old guy
on the mouth at the mall!
Let's go!
-I just got word that
our positive attitudes
and good bodies
cured coronavirus!
[ Cellphone chirps ]
Oh, wait.
Oh, no, no.
Uh, sorry.
Ruth's Chris Steak House
is delivering!
Oh!
-Oh, hello.
I'm Justice Ruth Bader Ginsberg,
and I wanted to say
a heartfelt hello
to everyone who's stuck inside.
I want to show you
some exercises you can do
while you're in there to stay,
you know, fit and healthy.
So, today we're gonna be working
all the major muscle groups
of the body.
We got the abs, gams, tuchus,
chicken wings,
and, uh, critical thinking.
So, let's go.
All you really need for a good
at-home workout
is a jump rope
and some weights.
You got to remember to start
by cleaning your equipment
with one of these
Lysol wipes.
I'm tiny, they're big.
What are you gonna do?
And these are my punching bags,
Kavanaugh and Gorsuch.
Alright, let's go.
Got to work out.
Don't want to gain
the quarantine 15 ounces.
And you got to eat healthy
to stay healthy.
Every day, I eat
a half a chicken.
Sorry. Chickpea.
Half a chickpea.
You got to pee a little bit
every time you move.
That's normal.
That's good.
That's the burn.
Social distancing is important.
Take it from me, I've been
social distancing
from Justice Alito since '03.
And that's a Gins-burn.
[ Mid-tempo hip-hop music
plays ]
♪♪
I'm very tough.
I'm 87 years old.
[ Breathing heavily ]
I survived cancer four times.
I went to law school
during the Spanish flu.
Beat it.
That's my trainer.
If I mess up, he eats me.
Scary guy.
[ Panther roar ]
If you're wondering, I'm not
using this time to relax.
I'm actually training
for the 2021 Olympics.
I'm gonna do mental gymnastics
to figure out
why they cut the pandemic
response team in 2018.
Hey.
Gins-burn.
♪♪
So, for these, I like
to push myself
with something really heavy.
[ Breathing heavily ]
[ Grunts ]
You got to get fit
to post your thirst traps.
I hope I crush these.
Dr. Fauci, answer my DMs.
[ Cellphone chimes ]
And that's a slow burn.
[ Sultry jazz plays ]
♪♪
[ Rubber stretching ]
Whew.
Got to cool down now and stretch
out with my foam roller.
It's a piece of mostaccioli.
Apparently, the virus
came from a sick bat,
which makes me wonder, what was
Giuliani doing in China?
Mitch McConnell said
that the administration
didn't focus on the virus
because they were too
distracted by impeachment.
I mean, are you in Congress
or Parliament?
'Cause your timeline
is funkadelic.
Funk me.
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
Anyway, thanks for tuning in.
And remember, stay healthy.
All you need to do
is one push-up.
A push-up is when you think,
"Hey, it's been two weeks,
maybe I'll put on a bra."
And that's a self-Gins-burn.
Drop the beat.
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
-I'm Desiree,
and this is Body Fuzion.
Do you wanna meet my friends?
-Donna.
-Michelle.
-Let's begin.
This is a low-impact level-one
workout.
But just because
it's low-impact,
doesn't mean you won't get...
high results.
Our first exercise
is called the step.
Step left, step right.
Left, right.
-Whoo!
-Left, right.
If this is not
challenging enough,
watch Michelle show you
the advanced style.
Left, right.
Left.
Or, take it easy,
and do it easier, like Donna M.
Left, right. Left, right.
Left, right.
Left.
This aligns our chakras
and helps "oxenygate" the blood.
Let's tone our arms.
You can use weights
or any household item.
-For a more advanced workout,
use 1-pound hand weights.
-Or pencils.
-Or air.
-Flexibility is important.
Breathe, and one, two, three.
Do the best you can.
Someone has done this before.
Take it to the limit.
[ Breathing deeply ]
If this is too difficult,
work your fingers.
That's all for today.
Put in tape 2 for an even
lower-level body workout.
Body Fuzion.
Yay!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪